one click and record your favorite song
in studio quality Austrian singer Melina
tetas is testing mic me a wireless
microphone the app allows her to process
the data directly from altering the
volume 2 recording individual tracks and
then combining them the 410 is a staff
the advantage is that it's so
user-friendly it's just one click for me
that's the main advantage often after
setting everything up the inspiration is
gone as few it is the hint the app was
developed by Philip sunlight now and
he's hoping it becomes a market leader
the first prototype was convincing
enough to get Sun lagna invited to the
pioneers festival in Vienna a gathering
for startups from all over the world
sixteen hundred companies from nearly 90
countries competed for an invitation
they were all eager to present their
products and find investors let's get
this demon home girl it's not just about
securing venture capital it's also about
meeting other startups yesterday I met
someone from South Korea who works in
the music business you never know what
might happen sounds very exciting
there's buns
the Pioneers festival provides a glimpse
of tomorrow's world one that might be
populated by robots that can imitate
human expressions a Berlin startup has
developed software that translates
movements into music moving different
parts of the body activates different
instruments
the American company Athos is embracing
the latest trend in the world of sports
athletic wear with sensors that register
which muscles are being used an app then
evaluates the data and provides tips on
maximizing the workout now you can find
a kid who's really fasted running and
then training him how was st. bull runs
and like all the other stars run prevent
them from having injuries and train them
to the maximum level without letting
them break down and now you can actually
start evolving human performance because
you're actually making that person
better but if entrepreneurs want to turn
their visions into reality they need to
impress people like Ali Valhalla of
speed invest the company helps startups
through the difficult development phase
he has about 60 million euros to invest
in new projects duhaney films on
startups half the startups that come to
us are not ambitious enough they're just
too modest they only think in terms of
the market in Austria Germany or Europe
they're only looking to corner a niche
that's the difference between us or
global startups even the founding team
needs to be a balanced team so hacker
hustler hipster then you'd be working on
something really interesting that they
actually authentically are interested in
fixing or sort of really working on and
it has to be a very big market
statistically speaking nine out of 10
startups fail everyone here at the
Pioneers festival is hoping their
company will be a game-changer Philip
sunlight nuh got himself a three-month
stint in Silicon Valley he's also made
important contacts
helping me out and goals Polacks poison
I spoke to some of the major publishers
and content creators if any and they
basically found the idea very cool
Debbie so maybe we're ready to
collaborate and find out where this
journey can take us with the Isaac in
the hole good sunlight nuh is planning
to return next year maybe as a speaker
sharing his expertise with the next
round of entrepreneurs chip says think
big